Local practitioner told me that distilled water is the only thing that takes out your radium.
Um, yeah, I don't know about that. I don't know if that's true or not.
It's typically not a lot of your radium in your water supplies.
But, um, I mean, I've had people with your radium toxicity.
I had one guy who wanted to hear a funny story. That funny.
This guy had major problems, major colon problems.
That effect he came to me as a last ditch effort because they were going to actually remove a large part of his quality did not have cancer.
Um, but the, um, he tested positive for your radium, but I thought, I have no idea.
And he lived in an area where you could, you could search the ground water.
Um, there's a website. I forgot the name of it. It's on our, it's on our website and I have a blog post about it.
But you could search the, you know, for local contaminants.
And nope, not in his water supply, not in anything like that. And then it turns out that his life has this collection of, um, you know what that antique glass, where is that's actually your radium glass.
The name of it, because they used your radium and the one or two.
To make the bomb, they changed the name of it to carnival glass.
Well, that is your any of it, especially the great stuff. It was a wife has this huge collection of it.
And he was a builder. They move every year. They build a spec house. They sell a spec house. They move builds another spec house.
Um, and he said I have to move and grab. I'm the one who has to handle all that glass where he was getting your any toxicity for that glass.